[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESTON HOLMES: Thank
you, everyone, for coming.
My name is Preston Holmes.
I'm part of our
IoT solutions team.
And today, I'm
going to be talking
to sort of about a cornucopia
of a variety of sort
of performance-related
thoughts that
can go into your IoT solutions.
So from the very
beginning, speed
has been part of
Google's philosophy.
And this was sort of published
in "10 Things We Know
To Be True" many years ago.
And in fact, back in
2009, we even began
running a number of experiments
of about, how does speed affect
the way people use Google?
So we would actually
inject intentional slowness
into Google search to just
a very random percentage
of users and measure,
how much were they still
interacting with Google?
How many searches
were they doing.
And we noticed just introducing
one to 400 milliseconds
of delay in Google search
decreased up to a half
a percent how many
searches people did.
And this idea of
very small amounts
of performance impacting the way
people interact with technology
also applies to e-commerce.
So a large e-commerce
place did some research
and found that for every
100 milliseconds of latency
added to their experience, it
actually reduced sales by 1%.
So speed definitely matters.
But what is speed?
When we say fast, it can be
an extremely relative concept.
So when we say something needs
to be fast, what do we mean?
Speed is measured through time.
Ranges from
nanoseconds to things
like weeks, months, and years.
So we have to think about
the context of time and speed
when we talk about performance.
So if we look at the very low
scale, less than a nanosecond.
What are things that happen
less than a nanosecond?
Well, it's the delay, the
time between each clock cycle
of like a three gigahertz CPU.
Or when you think about the
RF frequency and the vibration
of crystals emitting signals
for things like Wi-Fi--
less than a nanosecond
per frequency vibration.
And compared to something
like a microcontroller, which
you might find in an IoT
device, much slower, so
we have 125 nanoseconds between
each sort of rhythmic clock
cycle on something
like a eight-megahertz
microcontroller.
So we go up now
talking about something
around 20 milliseconds.
When you talk about controlling
things like servos or dimming
lights, you have what's
called pulse width modulation.
This is when you change
the duration of a signal
out one of your I/O pins.
And these typically are
about 20 milliseconds
in duration, these pulses.
Going to 50
milliseconds, this is
about the latency you're
going to find on the network
to reach your nearest
Google Cloud region overall.
It can be a little less.
It can be a little more.
But if you're talking about
sort of within your region,
it could be around
50 milliseconds
at just the link
side of that timing.
It's also about
the time it takes
for somebody tapping your
big toe to get to your brain.
We think of nerves and
sensation as being very fast,
but our nerves are actually
not that-- as sort of fast
as we think they are.
This is also about
the time you start
to perceive if you're watching
a video when somebody's
lip sync--
if the audio drifts
from the picture
is about 50 milliseconds.
Now, if we go to a
farther Cloud Region,
if we're going halfway
around the world or something
like, that on a good connection,
it can be 250 milliseconds.
So you can see that
this time scale
is sort of in our
long-distance networking frame.
It's also about the time
it takes to blink an eye.
So we often talk about
like in a blink of an eye
as being something very fast.
But this is now something
we consider rather
slow from a networking
point of view.
So we get into the kind of
next order of magnitude here.
BigQuery, while
it's very, very good
at very fast queries across
very large data sets,
it does take one
to three seconds
to sort of plan a
query in BigQuery.
For those of you that
live near the ocean,
there's something
called slack tide,
which is sort of this delay as
the tide sloshes in and then
out.
That's called slack tide.
That lasts about an hour.
And finally, out to a month is
something that you might see.
It takes about a
month for a strawberry
to go from flower to fruit.
So if you're a strawberry
farmer and you're
trying to optimize
operations, you probably
aren't caring about
10 nanoseconds of time
in the way the strawberry grows.
So every scale of time
has a different impact
on performance.
Performance is also
greatly impacted
by many layers in your
stack, so everything
from the physics
of the equipment
you're using up to
the application layer.
So down at the
physics layer, this
might be something like
the thermal capacitance
of a temperature sensor.
If you're looking for
100-millisecond latency
on variation of
temperature, the truth
is the temperature sensor
itself has thermal capacitance,
and you can't heated up
or cool it down that fast.
It has its own inertia.
So the physics can't give you
that kind of time resolution
of temperature.
On the device, you're going to
deal not only with things like
the processor speed, but also if
you're using any sort of analog
to digital converter-- we'll
talk about the performance
of those systems--
you've got to send
this information
over a potential variety
of local and long-ranging
communications protocols.
Each of those can
affect the performance.
Everything you do with the data,
ingesting it and processing it
on the Cloud side, is obviously
going to have some impact.
And finally, there's
a set of things
around the way you can
develop your applications
and the way performance
is perceived.
And that gets into more about
how we, as humans, can sort
of be fooled into performance.
So we'll talk a little
bit about each of these.
But before we go into them, we
need to know a little bit more
about how we measure
and communicate
when we talk about performance.
And we're going to use this
analogy of moving water
from one place to another.
And there are really three
terms and three concepts
that are used when
measuring performance.
And that is operations,
latency, and throughput.
So operations is
essentially, how many times
can I do this task,
say, in an hour?
The latency is, how
long does it take
me to carry one bucket
from point A to point B?
And throughput
often ends up being
a bit of a combination
of the two,
which is at the end of the
hour, how many gallons of water
have I moved?
Now, there's more than one
way to achieve throughput.
So you can take
three smaller buckets
and move them in series, one
after another, very quickly
with very low latency.
Or you can move one
larger bucket more slowly,
and it results in
the same throughput.
You can move three
buckets concurrently.
And again, same latency in the
situation and same throughput.
Or you can combine combinations
of concurrency, latency, et
cetera to increase
your throughput,
not necessarily by increasing
the size of each payload.
Now, what's interesting
about these three measures
is how widely they
apply to a variety
of different
performance scenarios.
So this same measurement
is applied to how
you measure disk operation.
So operations, if
you hear of IOPS
when you're talking
about hard drives
or spinning disk versus SSD,
how many IOPS can a disk do,
that's operations.
So this idea of
performance applies
to very small
local measurements,
such as between the CPU and
subsystems on the same board.
But we can also think
of them as applying
to how data moves
from the device
all the way to the application
that's running on the Cloud.
So first, let's start at
the lower layers here.
So fundamental to what,
in my mind defines,
IoT is analog to digital.
The world is full of all of this
infinitely resolution analog
information.
And the first step
in IoT is often
to digitize that into something
we can transmit on the wire.
Now, analog signals are
inherently infinite resolution,
both in time and
in terms of value.
So in x and y-axis, they're
essentially infinite
resolution.
And obviously, we don't
have infinite resolution
in computation, so the
analog-to-digital converter
quantiles that data and samples
it to turn it into binary data
that we can send.
And different analog-to-digital
converters, or ADCs,
have different
performance capabilities.
And the way you
measure the performance
is in these two ways,
resolution and sample rate.
So resolution is, how
many different values
can you apply to that y-axis?
If you have, for
example, a seven-bit ADC,
you can only get 127 values,
potentially, in your y-axis.
And if it's eight-bit,
you have 256.
So that's your resolution.
And then the sampling rate
is, how many times per second
are you sampling
these vertical lines?
How often are you
sampling the value?
And while those
sampling rates are often
going to be very
high, and much higher
than you're going to be sending
or transmitting telemetry
to the cloud, it's
important to know
what the performance
of that sampling rate
is if you're trying to observe
subtle physical phenomenon
that's happening at
very fine resolution,
either acoustic or
vibrational, something
subtle in your analog
signal that you
need to be able to capture and
then convert into something
you can send to the Cloud.
The other thing is to
think about time and clocks
on a device.
So clocks have one
set of time, which
is the relative time
of how many cycles
it's run since it booted.
But you really need generally
some form of connection
to the real world time.
Right now, it's 12:44.
How does your device
know that it's 12:44?
And that's through
the real-time clock.
So these need to be set either
manually through a touch panel
or through some
sort of protocol,
like Network Time Protocol.
They're usually
battery backed so
that if the device
powers off and on again,
it still has the current time.
It doesn't have to be reset.
The quality of these real-time
clocks is measured as drift.
And what's interesting, if
you've ever seen air quality
measurements in
parts per million,
drift in real-time
clocks is also
measured in parts per million.
So 100 parts per million
drift in a measurement of,
how good is this clock, means
that in a million seconds,
it will drift 100 seconds.
And that's actually
eight seconds a day.
You can see how that could
kind of quickly build up.
So actually, most
real-time clocks
are far more accurate than that.
And this matters because time
is used in a number of places
in your IoT solution.
First, it's used in
the authentications.
So you're not only
checking, say,
the validity of a
TLS certification
when it might expire.
But on IoT Core, we
enforce that the timing
of our authentication token
drift no more than 10 minutes
outside of our server's time.
So 10 minutes should cover
most real-time clock scenarios.
But if you're
outside of that, we
won't recognize that
as a valid credential.
Further, you want
to have the time set
across multiple devices in
your servers all to as close
to the same time as you can
if you're trying to correlate
events across multiple devices.
If one device is
set to one time,
and another device
is set to another,
and you're trying
to understand how
two events are
related in time, they
need to share a common base.
And finally, if you're
looking at monitoring
the performance of
your system and you're
trying to measure latency,
say, from the transmit time
of a device to the Cloud, you
need a shared time across those
to accurately measure latencies.
And we're going to
see that a bit later.
So a quick tip--
we offer very highly-accurate
free NTP service
at time.google.com.
Now, real-time is a phrase.
We're going to see
this a couple of times.
Real-time systems you
may have heard of.
And one of the places
is, is it relates
to the kind of
operating systems.
So most of us are using a
CPU and a typical Linux-like
operating system, where
application and system
processes all have access to
the lower layers of the hardware
through a kernel.
And with a kernel,
there are tasks
that are running that
can be preempted.
And the kernel can essentially
arbitrate which process
gets access to the hardware.
And that's sometimes
not always advantageous
when it comes to IoT.
With a microcontroller,
the application
can have high priority access
directly to the peripherals.
And where that
matters is when you're
talking to hardware or
sensors or peripherals
that have very strict
boundary timing
on the-- say, the
durations of certain pulses
that need to be consistent.
Your application
that's communicating
on that kind of protocol
needs direct access
to the peripherals
at essentially
a potentially
microsecond-level accuracy.
So when you hear about RTOSes,
or real-time operating systems,
that generally means
that there's not
a kernel in the middle that
could preempt you from getting
access to the peripherals.
So that's a bunch of
things on your devices.
But what are some places that
Google invests at these lower
layers of the actual
physical infrastructure that
can affect your performance?
And I've pulled out
just three of them.
One of them is our investment
in the long lengths of fiber.
Now, the speed of light
is about the fastest way
we know to transmit information.
I actually happen to work
alongside our quantum computing
group, so potentially, they can
do quantum entanglement someday
that could be somehow
instantaneous.
But we're not there yet.
So speed of light
is our best bet.
Speed of light
through glass fiber
is a little bit slower than
speed of light through air,
but it's still the
best we can do.
So we've invested heavily
in a lot of undersea fiber
optic cables to make those
long jumps as fast as possible.
Inside the data
center, we've also
invested in a whole bunch of
software-defined networking
and a set of cost-based
topology in our switches
to make sure that
we have the most
throughput between services
within our data center.
And then finally, we've been
working on custom silicon
to accelerate machine learning,
both training and inference.
And as you may have heard just
in this morning's keynote,
we've launched Edge TPU to
bring that kind of performance
to machine learning out
onto the devices itself.
So these are just three
areas where we're also
investing in the actual
physical hardware
to increase performance.
So now, we have our sort of
physical layers and hardware
layers a little bit covered.
Let's talk about how
you package information.
So when you're
sending messages, you
need to describe and
package a message.
And the first thing
you want to consider
is, how are you going
to serialize this?
Are you going to use
JSON or something binary?
And the way you encode a
message can impact how much time
it takes on a device.
It also impacts decoding
it on the Cloud side.
But you might be more
concerned about the duration
of time it takes on the device.
How large the
resulting message is
will affect how fast you
can send it over the wire,
but it's also going
to affect the cost
of storing these messages as
they accumulate over time.
And you need to consider whether
these messages are important
to you more from a
latency point of view
or more from a
throughput point of view.
All of these can
affect the decisions
around how you
describe the messages.
The serialization is going
to decide also the format,
whether or not you need to
have a schema, or description,
of your message on either side.
So some formats are
self-describing and more
schema-less, like JSON.
Others, like protocol
buffers, require that each--
the sender and the
receiver know in advance
the structure, or the
schema, of the message.
So Uber took quite
a long look at this,
and they compared across several
different serialization formats
and binary and
compression formats.
And while you can't
read all these,
essentially, the y-axis
is, how much time
did it take to encode
and decode a given type?
And the x-axis is, what is the
size of the resulting payload?
And so the lower left
is sort of the best.
It took the least
amount of time,
and it resulted in
the smallest message.
And so you'll see things like
protocol buffers and zlib
compression and
thrift down here,
whereas JSON is way out here.
So while JSON's very
comfortable and familiar to us,
it's not necessarily always
the most efficient way
to send messages.
Now, moving up,
there's going to be--
this is a very rapid
and high-density talk.
Hope you guys appreciate that.
So as we go now,
we're sending messages
over some sort of
a transport layer.
There's a lot of these different
protocols of communication
out there.
And let's quickly review.
On the right hand side
are sort of layers
one through four of the
OSI layering here, which is
that the layer one is really--
I think of it is that
the wires and waves,
how things move as currents or
radio waves through the air.
Layer two is how you sort
of frame the messages
on that carrier signal.
And it's not until
layers three and four
that we really get into
internet of things, IP protocol.
However, there's a lot of
information in IoT solutions
that spend some part of their
journey as non-IP traffic.
And that might be over local
area connections or wider area
connections.
So locally, we have a
number of mesh protocols.
So the performance
of, how many hops
will that message make
on a mesh protocol,
will affect your latency.
Other protocols, which are
more legacy or industrial,
are bound by the carrier signal.
So modbus or other
RS45-type protocols, they're
limited to how fast they
can transmit information
by their very design.
On the long-range side, you
have to consider whether you're
most concerned with
throughput, in which case, you
might be looking more
for something like 5G,
or cost and low bandwidth, which
you'd be looking at something
like nb-iot or Sigfox or LoRA.
So these are all
essentially different levers
and knobs you have on the
transport layer to consider.
The other one is to think
about the protocol you're
sending over these transports.
So IoT Core, we offer
both MQTT and HTTP.
But there's going to
be some differences.
And one of the biggest
ones is that MQTT
is a stateful protocol,
meaning you open a connection,
and then, you can
use that connection
for multiple messages.
While HTTP is more
inherently stateless,
and you need to set
up and tear down
a connection for each
message you send.
And you can see that
over time, that overhead
of establishing
connections not only
impact performance but
also power consumption.
The other thing is that with
MQTT, since it's stateful,
when you update a
device's configuration,
it can be pushed essentially
immediately down to a device,
whereas with MQTT, you
have to pull and see if you
have any update config waiting.
Furthermore, HTTP is
a text-based protocol.
You cannot send binary
payloads directly over HTTP.
You have to base64 encode them.
That inflates the
size of the payload.
You're going to pay a penalty on
the wire for those extra bytes
of that base64 encoding.
Inside a message, you
also need to think about,
is there a way to economize
and batch information
in a single message?
So you might say that you
have many sensor readings,
and they're all taken at
approximately the same time.
Well, you can send one
time stamp and multiple
readings in a single
message, and you
have reduced the overhead
of your actual payload.
Now, you have to balance that
benefit of combining messages
into one message with
the fact that if you
need to process
them independently,
you may be paying
another sort of tax
for that on the Cloud
side, because you're
going to have to
unpack those messages.
So the degree that you can gain
efficiency in the transmitting
by packing more information
into a single message
versus the unpacking
on the Cloud
will be something to consider.
But if you think about
all of the metadata
about a message
that might be shared
across multiple messages, that
represents a set of overhead
that you can economize on by
using a thicker message type.
All right, so very
briefly, I think--
how many people realize that
they're using HTTP/2 every day?
So most people, I
don't think, recognize
that there's been this sort
of radical transformation
that's happened in HTTP land
over the last several years.
This is largely led
by Google's efforts
to really improve the efficiency
and way in the way web content
is delivered.
So it used to be that
you'd open a web page.
The web page would
load a bunch of images
and pull down a bunch of CSS.
And each of those was
another HTTP connection.
It was very inefficient.
So we looked at sort of
redesigning the way HTTP works.
Now, we open something
much more like a stream
that we can pipeline multiplex,
multiple pieces of information
over the same channel.
We deal with flow control,
so no head of line
blocking, things like that.
And we can push messages down.
And this has really improved
the efficiency of the web.
We've gone one step
further, and we also
have an open RPC protocol that
pushes our sort of API methods
over HTTP/2, and
that's called gRPC.
There's a whole bunch
about gRPC I won't go into,
but essentially,
it also allows you
to find services and clients
in multiple languages.
And this all rides over
the transport of HTTP/2.
So IoT Core today delivers a lot
of its telemetry-- essentially,
all of its telemetry
over a Cloud Pub/Sub.
And Cloud Pub/Sub has been
an early and avid supporter
of gRPC as a protocol.
However, Pub/Sub isn't
something that is as simple
as you might think.
You'd sort of imagine, oh
yeah, publish a message,
and that subscriber just
simply gets the message.
And that's it.
But there's a lot of knobs
and decisions available to you
about tuning the
performance of Pub/Sub,
and the first is whether
you do push or pull.
Now push, you have
this overhead,
as I was describing with
connection of, one message
at a time to an HTTP endpoint.
It's not necessarily
a very efficient way
of getting a lot of
throughput out of Pub/Sub.
We now support, through gRPC,
streaming or async pull,
in which you can establish
a connection from a client
and do streaming
messages from Pub/Sub.
And this allows you to
attain much higher throughput
than you would be from even
batch pulling messages.
So this is something you
definitely want to look at.
I think the takeaway
with performance
and Pub/Sub so is
understand that if you
try a naive or
simple measurement,
you might need to do some tuning
to get the optimum throughput
out of Pub/Sub.
And one of those things is
we'll parallelize consumption.
So you can do streaming
pull from a single thread,
but then you can also
have multiple threads
or multiple processes
doing streaming pull.
And all of that will
increase throughput.
The other type of way
in which parallelization
can happen on Cloud is if you're
using Cloud Functions, Cloud
Functions themselves
will scale out.
Each function can
run concurrently
across many instances.
And finally, you can
use parallelization
in your data processing.
So now, we're
moving up the stack
now into sort of data
processing, data management.
So you can use techniques
such as MapReduce and Apache
Beam and Dataflow to
process data in parallel
that will get you through
your data processing tasks
much faster.
And in fact, in
Dataflow, there's
one particular thing I
want to kind of call out
which is pretty
interesting, and that
is if anyone's worked with
data processing systems,
like MapReduce,
the first task is
that you divide a huge mountain
of work up into smaller chunks.
And then, you divvy up all these
chunks to all these workers.
The truth is that task
of divvying up work
is not a very perfect
step in the process.
And some workers
end up with kind
of a crummier batch of
work than other workers,
and they take longer.
And so your actual
job duration is really
limited by the slowest
worker of your set.
And you can see that
on the left hand side
with these long-tooth combs.
Those represent workers that
got more work than others.
And so the job does not complete
until the last worker is done.
With a feature called Dynamic
Work Rebalancing in Dataflow,
this is actually
dynamically reapportioned
to different workers mid-job
so that the whole job completes
faster.
And that's not only going to
be faster to sort of result.
That's also less compute
time you pay for,
because you're not paying for
idle workers who have completed
their task early.
Now, let's talk
about high data rate.
Whenever we're talking
about very high data rates,
there's a whole bunch
of things to consider.
So first of all, what
is your requirement
around the integrity
of your data?
If you require very high
consistency and high integrity
around every message,
you will need things
like locks and transactions.
Now, a number of database
products and storage systems
will give you
transactions, but they all
come with some
performance costs.
So if you need
that, it's something
you need to consider into
your performance budget.
The other thing is
many storage products
suffer from some degree of
hotspotting if you simply
try to write all of your values
in a very narrow key space.
So most distributed
systems use some form
of distributed hash
charting to make sure
that everything is spread out
across many back end nodes.
And if your keys tend to
all land on the same node,
that system will slow
down and get burdened.
So if you're using things
like timestamps in your keys,
you need to make
sure there's enough
randomness in the
preceding part of the key
so that you're not
converging on one system.
And we'll see a demo of
this in just a moment.
The other is if you're
willing to trade off
some degree of
durability, there's
really no beating the
performance of memory.
I mean, nothing
is faster than RAM
when it comes to computation.
So if you're willing to expose
yourself to some risk of loss
and some risk of a little
bit of reduced durability,
you can support a much
higher rate of computation
if you're only keeping
a value in memory.
And that brings us
to rate limiting.
So rate limiting
is something that's
there to protect systems
against overuse or higher costs.
It's something that you
should be considering
in designing your
systems, that you
should be rate limiting any
consumers of your services
to protect the performance
of your system.
But you also need to
consider, how capable is
that system of handling rate
limiting and the back pressure
you might provide?
So if you're working
with a legacy system,
it might be more
incumbent upon you
to simply scale as best you can,
because that system may simply
break if you return
a 429 rate exceeded.
So if it can't handle it,
you might need to deal that.
You also need to be able to
handle being rate limited,
potentially, or be aware of
any rate limits of systems
that you're relying on.
But there are some
tricks around this.
So I'm going to show a demo
of this quick solution.
And the idea is
here, we're trying
to write a counter
value into Cloud
Firestore at a very high rate.
Now, Cloud Firestore
has a rate limit
per document of one write
per second per document.
So if I'm trying to update
a counter in Firestore
at a very high rate, the most
I can write into Firestore
for that value is
once per second.
So what I'm doing in
this solution here
is I'm using Redis,
an in-memory counter,
and I'm updating that in-memory
counter at very high rates.
And then, I'm using another
rate limiter attached to that
and writing into Firestore
once every couple seconds.
So let's see if I can
do a quick demo of this.
So here, we have Cloud Firestore
and a very simple layout where
we have one collection, Demo;
one document called Counter;
and one field called Count.
What I'm going to do is run
a little kind of load tester
here.
And what this is going to do
is hammer my Cloud Function.
So you're going to see
this Cloud Function's
probably gone a bit quiescent.
The counter will start
up a little slow.
But using a rate of 200 requests
per second for 80 seconds,
I'm going to hit
this Cloud Function.
I might refresh.
So it did work.
Sometimes, you've got to reload
this dashboard if it's lost.
So you're going to see
this value of the count
go up as the Cloud
Function warms up.
You'll see this increase
every few seconds.
But what's happening
is Redis is maintaining
a high-speed counter
in memory and then,
every couple of seconds,
writing the current count
into Firestore.
So this is a rate of
increase that you could never
put directly into Firestore.
If you tried to write every
increment of this counter
into Firestore, you'd just start
getting errors from Firestore,
because it's protecting
itself with the rate limiting.
So this is kind
of a technique you
can use to balance performance
of different layers
of your system with some degree
of trade-off of throughput
and rate and durability.
All right, I very
quickly can kind of just
walk you through a little
bit of what this looks like.
We have a function
counter limit.
It establishes a rate
limiter based on Redis.
Actually, I have
a laser pointer.
I can help you guys quickly.
Here, the rate limiter
is established.
I increment Redis here.
No matter what, I can increment
Redis, because Redis basically
has close to infinite counts--
the ability, in the
system, at least.
And then here, I check
whether my rate limiter
has any available capacity.
So rate limiting is
usually done in some form
of where you have a certain
number of operations
in a window of time.
So I'm sort of setting a rate
limit of once every three
seconds here.
And then if I have available
capacity on my rate limiter,
I will write out to Firestore,
write out the document.
That's all the code for
what that demo essentially
does right there.
So now, we're up into
the application layer,
so a couple points, a couple of
slides here on the application.
So the first thing you can do
is when you're dealing with
different types of data--
and say it's time series--
if you're collecting data,
say, from every 30 seconds,
but most of your users are
interested in something that's
an average of an hour, you don't
need to compute that average
for every user for every view.
You should be pre-computing
certain information
that people are
going to be working
with in the application.
There is a wide range of
caching techniques out there.
I'm not going to
go into them all.
But caching is an important
part around the performance
of your application.
If there's certain data you
know everybody is looking for,
have that available
in a cache somewhere,
potentially even at
the presentation layer.
So I'm a big believer still in
the power of web applications.
And web applications are
becoming more and more capable.
In the browser,
in the client, you
can do quite a bit in terms
of pre-computing information
in your local
application and then
sending back to Cloud
something every few moments.
If somebody is dragging
a slider, for example,
you don't need to send
every loop of the browser.
You don't need to send
a value to the Cloud.
You might do it only once
the slider is released,
that kind of thing.
You can be proactive,
and this can really
improve the perceived
performance of an application.
So again, in Firestore, it has
a system called Firestore watch.
That allows all of the clients,
all of the applications
that are interested in
the piece of information
to watch for any change.
When that value has
changed in the database,
it's immediately pushed
out to all the clients.
So there is no need
to write a polling
loop in your application
if that information is
pushed immediately.
Firestore also has a feature
called latency compensation.
So in complex
applications, you might
have one piece of information
in the application that
affects many other parts
of the application.
And when you change a value
in the client in Firestore,
it actually returns
the write immediately
to the rest of the
application optimistically.
So this is compensating for
latency to the back end.
It then has metadata
that tells you,
does this write actually
have a pending Cloud write,
or is it completed?
And so you can differentiate
that in your app.
But you don't have to
build your app to assume--
to wait for the long trip, round
trip for the-- to the response.
The other thing is--
again, remember when I talked
about the frame being--
spanning from
nanoseconds to minutes--
performance sometimes is about
minutes to hours to people
right.
If you use push notifications
in an application,
you bring to
somebody's attention
that there's something happening
they should care about.
And that can get them back into
the application within minutes,
as opposed to at
the end of the day,
they think to check the
status of something.
So push notifications
are another way
of being proactive
with your users.
And then finally
things that I put
in this category of
suggested responses
are we all use everyday
applications that are very
helpful in auto-completing.
If you go to the same
web page every day
and you start to type
that URL in Chrome,
it ranks it up there
right at the top.
It knows which is most active.
And that saves many, many
seconds of our interactions
with applications every day.
So think about how to be
proactive in suggesting
responses at the
application layer.
And finally,
offline-- all right,
so this is something where
obviously as a Cloud platform,
we're interested in the
application tying greatly
to capabilities that
we offer on the Cloud.
But we also recognize
that applications still
need to function offline.
So if we're thinking about
things in a browser--
we have things that we've
really been investing recently
at Google called progressive
web applications.
It allows web applications
news local storage
and web workers to maintain a
fully functioning experience
while the machine's offline.
Firestore also will
sync data locally
to the local storage system
or the browser offline,
so the application can
continue to function.
I mentioned Edge TPU earlier.
The idea of running
inference on the Edge
means that if you have a
critical behavior and the use
of ML on a device on
the Edge, that behavior
needs to persist
and be functional,
even if you've lost a
connection to the Cloud,
so being able to
do ML on the Edge.
And I would actually
argue that--
be mindful about having
Cloud in the loop,
in the application loop in
terms of the user's experience.
The canonical idea
that you're going
to flip a light switch
and the light turns on,
it's probably not a best
place to put hard dependency
of having Cloud in that loop.
Have that loop happen locally
offline, and then async,
keep that data synchronized,
or report it to the Cloud.
But don't put a Cloud path
in a critical performance
path on a local
application experience.
So monitoring-- you cannot
improve the performance
of something you're
not measuring.
And there's a lot
you can be measuring.
So you can be measuring
performance of the hardware,
performance of the device.
You can be measuring the
performance of application
software either on the device
or at the presentation layer.
You can be measuring
performance of the network,
either something we provide
you on our part of the network
or something that
you measure yourself
from the end-to-end reality
of your device to a server.
So it's very critical.
It's almost nonsensical to talk
about knowing your performance
or improving your performance
if you don't have measurements
that you can tell whether
you've made an improvement.
I'm going to show another
brief demo-- oh, all right--
switched the order up on
myself here a little bit.
When you're talking about
measurements of performance,
it's really important
to understand
that some measurements are a
lot more useful and valuable
than others.
And one of them that can be
not so helpful is an average.
This is a quick graph of
two distributions of data
that have the
exact same average,
but obviously, they're
very different.
If you were only measuring
an average for these two data
sets, they would look identical
to your reporting system.
You would say, oh, no,
we have a average of 100.
It's great.
But clearly, the distribution
of this data is very different.
So what is common in
monitoring systems
is to look at
percentiles or quantiles,
where you're essentially looking
at buckets of information
across a distribution,
and you're caring about,
potentially, what are most
of our requests doing,
or what is our lowest 10%
of all of our requests?
So if you see numbers
like P99 or P95,
or how many nines
of what your latency
is at three 9s,
those kind of things,
these are all dealing with
quantiles and percentiles.
So back to the demo.
Oh, no.
I think my battery has died.
So I have a backup.
So I have a device
that's been publishing,
except it has
tuckered out on me,
so the backup here is
I have a screen shot.
I'm gonna see if I can't
get this to come back online
while I do this, but I'll go
through the screenshot first.
So what we have here
in the screenshot
is the measurement of the
publish acknowledgment
latency over MQTT to IoT Core.
And so this is a measurement
that we can't provide you
on the Cloud side.
This can only be observed
from the device side.
So if a device is sending
a message over MQTT,
we do a couple
interesting things for you
on the performance side
and the durability side.
So what we do is when we
take the message from MQTT
and write it to Pub/Sub, we
will not acknowledge the message
on MQTT until after it's been
written to Pub/Sub so that when
you get an acknowledgment
on the MQTT protocol,
you actually know that data has
already arrived safely and been
delivered into Cloud
Pub/Sub, and Cloud Pub/Sub
is a highly-durable,
highly-reliable system.
But you might care about like,
well, how long did that take?
From the device side, when
do I get acknowledgment
on the device side?
And because the network
is not a perfect system,
not every message is going
to have identical latency.
And what you want to know when
you're looking at the quantiles
here is, what's the
average speed of my,
like, best half of
all my messages.
So that would be your 0.5 here.
I'm going to see if I'm
lucky enough the demo gods--
yeah.
So I'm starting to get data now.
I'm going after switch my time
resolution to the last five
minutes to get
anything useful here.
So you can see here that I
can look at that measurement
and see, as I hover
over each of these,
what the performance of
each of these measures
is, what each of
these buckets is.
And so if you see
a very high spread,
that may or may
not matter to you.
But if you have
a user who's sort
of reporting, or somehow you're
trying to debug something--
you're saying, wow, sometimes
something seems to take a long
time; is it in my system--
well, you may see something
like a 95th percentile that's
slower.
And that might be
fine, because you
know that 95% of
your messages are
getting through within
some faster rate than that.
But that's good to know.
And if you were simply measuring
your average latencies,
you wouldn't know.
You'd lose that information.
You'd lose that insight
into, what is the range,
or what is the
distribution of performance
I'm seeing in these systems?
You can do the
same kind of thing
not only in this publish
acknowledgments speed on MQTT
but at any other
leg of your system.
And you can, in fact,
build distributed traces
of these kind of things over
the whole end-to-end span.
So I've pulled up here
also that there's--
the idea of monitoring
not only applies
to the sort of inward-looking
monitoring and measuring
of information around the
performance of your system,
but it can be externally-facing
through the sensors themselves.
So the lower two graphs
here show the light level.
And if I if I sort
pull out the device--
now that it's restarted here,
it's got a little light sensor.
It's got a little display.
And you'll see that as it
gets into the stage lighting,
this should tick
up significantly.
And so sometimes, the
same kind of monitoring
you're going to do might
be relevant for monitoring
the performance of
your physical systems.
So we've been talking
a lot about monitoring
the performance of the
devices or the infrastructure
of the Cloud.
But if you're interested
in the performance of,
say, a garage door--
use a sort of trivial
example here--
and saying, hey, you
know, the garage door is
all of a sudden taking
a lot longer to open,
or a furnace is taking
a lot longer to warm up,
these are-- now, we're
talking about the performance
of the actual
applications of IoT
as opposed to the performance
of the infrastructure
and the technology
supporting IoT.
But the truth is it's
time series data,
and it's data that is
operationally relevant to you.
So the same tools can
apply relatively equally.
So demo recovery there.
All right, and then just a
quick comment about cost,
because performance can often
be improved if you throw
a lot of money at a problem.
If you're worried about handling
huge surges of information,
you can simply have a lot of
very expensive standby capacity
ready to process it.
If you want to
economize on cost,
you may work-- you just may
let auto-scaling systems
sort of scale out
and handle the load.
One of the great
things about Pub/Sub
is it has essentially
instantaneous elasticity
on the publishing side.
It'll act as that
surge tank right.
So if you all of a sudden want
to publish 100,000 messages,
you can do that.
It might fill up a
queue, and you may not
want to have 20 servers
standing by expensively waiting
to process them all, but you've
at least handled the ingestion
instantaneously.
So certain things align
with performance and cost.
Certain things are not.
So IoT Core and Pub/Sub,
you really build on bytes.
You are not build to have
a faster byte transmitted.
So there really
isn't a extra cost
associated with more
performance for things
like IoT Core or Pub/Sub.
Other services, like Bigtable,
if you want more throughput,
more performance, you
actually do pay more
for more throughput.
So there is a correlation there
between cost and performance.
Memory is an expensive thing.
If you want to have the
performance of Redis
for that high-speed
counter, you need
to essentially have RAM on hand
for those kind of operations.
So in general, you
need to be optimizing
not only for
performance and cost--
and you should be looking at
how the impact of increasing
performance increases your cost
or where you get performance
essentially for free that's
built into the pricing model.
So in conclusion, I think be
mindful of where performance
actually has impact.
The phrase "premature
optimization" is real.
If you're worried about
20 milliseconds somewhere
on a publishing speed but
you have a transmit time
of 800 milliseconds
over a satellite link,
is that your biggest
concern at the moment?
Should you be really trying to
shave two or three milliseconds
or microseconds off of
something on the device
if it's really just
a rounding error
in your end-to-end latency?
So consider each
of these layers.
So just to review-- the
physical layer, what
is the-- if you look at
some boards, for example,
I mentioned temperature.
Do you need to isolate the
temperature sensor away
from the board so that it's
more responsive to changes
in temperature?
On the device, do you need
more compute or less compute?
Can you get away with an
eight-bit microprocessor,
or do you need
something like a CPU?
Do you need Edge TPU
you on the device
to do complex ML computation
on the device or not?
Is the communication something
you want to pay for 5G?
Do you need the
throughput, or do you just
care about the latency?
If you don't care
about the latency,
can you deal with
something like nb-iot
and just send up
hourly telemetry,
and that's sufficient?
So don't go and buy a
very high-throughput,
high-expensive connection
if you don't actually--
are not going to sort
of take advantage of it.
And then on the
data side, recognize
that you've got everything
from managed services,
like Pub/Sub, which will be
highly performant for you to--
sort of choices
you need to make.
If you're going to
run a VM, you'll
need to do things like
choose whether or not
to use SSD or spinning disk, how
much RAM, what instance type.
All of these variables on
the data processing side
can impact your performance.
And then on the presentation
layer on the application side,
remember that when you're
dealing with humans,
we can be fooled.
The perception of performance is
what matters on the application
side, often.
And so dealing with
caching, even if it's not
the freshest data, are your
users going to be happier
with a zippier experience,
or do they really
need the data from
one second to go?
Or can you cache for five
minutes, and everyone
is just happier because the
application loads instead
of waiting for a bunch of back
end processes to recompute?
So across the spectrum,
optimize for performance.
One quick plug for those who
are still around tomorrow
and wondering what to do.
We have a project we've been
working on for DevOps, so this
is a project for my team to
sort of make a fun game, kind
of a quest and a challenge
around doing DevOps live
with a bunch of
people and competing
and time and challenges.
So that's tomorrow afternoon
if anyone wants to do that.
I'll be around for
a couple of minutes.
If anyone has any questions,
I'm happy to entertain them.
But thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]